Hopefully what you learned from the previous example is that building
a random test case generator doesn't have to be very difficult.
But realistically, it's usually a little bit more involved than the one we just saw.
And the key problem is generating inputs that are valid.
Or another way to say that is generating inputs that are part of the input domain
for the software under test.
What I wanted to do here is look at the entire space of random inputs.
And what I mean by entire space of random inputs is we haven't ruled anything out.
So what we get is random 1s and 0s.
And so remember that request to constructing random inputs,
we're going to be feeding those into some software under test
and we're looking for outputs in the range of the software under test.
And let's say for the sake of argument that we're testing a web browser.
And so the question we have to ask ourselves is how much of the space of totally random 1s and 0s
constitutes a valid input for a web browser and when I say the word testing, they're rendering
it in part of a web browser so we're testing what happens when data comes over the web
to the web browser in response to an HTTP request
and now the web browser wants to render that.
So we have total random 1s and 0s.
And as you might expect almost all arbitrary combinations of 1s and 0s
fail to create valid web pages so there's going to be some small subset of the set of random inputs
that constitutes valid inputs to the web browser and if we take one of these other inputs
and hand it to the web browser there's going to mapped to a part of the output space
that corresponds to a malformed HTML.
One thing we might ask is, "Isn't it a good thing to test web browsers with completely invalid inputs
to see if for example instead of returning a page error it's easily possible
that some subset of this space corresponds to browser crashes?"
The answer is yes. We definitely do want to test our web browser with completely random inputs.
But on the other hand, the amount of code in the web browser that serves to classify codes as
renderable versus not renderable
there's some very tiny fraction of the total amount of code in the web browser.
And if the fraction of valid HTML is very low, we're going to spend almost all of our time testing
this very small part of the web browser.
What we probably want to do is take some tests from this broader set of completely random inputs
but take most of our tests from a set of valid webpages.
These are the ones which when we select a random input in here are going to
with some probability end up exposing something like cross-site scripting bugs.
Now I'm just going to ignore the little details like the fact that we probably would need to be
generating JavaScript as well in order to make these kind of bugs happen.
We're mostly trying to look at the abstract problem.